which murder do you want to see first
we're gonna pick this up just prior to
the murder here we've got three cars
plus the shooter here they're gonna kill
a guy right here in this alleyway here
in about a minute and a half I'm gonna
go a little faster than real time here
you have a protection car in green you
have your shooter in yellow you have
your getaway car in red you have another
protection car in yellow and you're
gonna see the shooter come right down
this alleyway here sorry
there's your shooter this purple car
just appears to be lost and stumbles
into the middle of the murder so here we
have our shooter right here I'm gonna
turn off that that track just so you can
see him there's what our shooter looks
like right there that little dot right
there he's going to step back there's
our victim right there right there
appears to be the shot to the head again
the police report said man found in an
alleyway shot no witnesses he was shot
in the head the shooter runs off gets
into the second car there and drives off
well here's all your no witnesses they
actually run after down the alleyway
after the shooter that tells us they're
armed and not only the armed but they
have some role in protection so they
came out looked at the body ran down and
to see if they could capture the guy who
shot him
so now unlike a predator we can go back
in time and I'm gonna bring those cars
back and here's our shooter running out
of here and there's the shot there's our
shooter running out getting into the
second vehicle and driving off
now we're gonna jump over on to and see
if we can follow that car so here's our
shooter here you can see the three cars
this is a protection car this is our
shooter car this is a guy who appears to
be paying and coordinating the murder
and we're gonna follow them out you can
see the yellow car on the wrong side of
the road passing on the right passing on
the Left wrong side of the road running
the red light this guy runs the
light because you know after you kill
someone the traffic laws don't apply to
you right so we're following this guy up
here and what our analysts are doing is
they're looking for people getting in
getting out right here you know see a
guy get out of the car gets out of the
passenger side same side the shooter got
into he's gonna go right into that
building there this is your other car up
here you know see this guy here he's
gonna go right into that building there
so here's what these guys do over about
a four and a half hour period every
place they come to every place they go
to so one of the things we found is that
we follow the people from the murder
scene we see this guy run all the way
over here we watch three people walk
back look at the body for a couple of
minutes and then two of them walk back
or they meet with a group and then two
of them walk back we think what happened
is someone said go get the boss guy runs
get the boss the boss comes back tells
all these people what they got to do
right well interestingly this is kind of
an interesting thing we looked at all
the other people who come to this
location shortly after the murder we get
two vehicles here one arrives all the
way from the south comes up here and
waits another one arrives from the north
waits here at the gas station together
at the same time they proceeded down
this road one guy get they both get
waved off one guy turns around comes
back and waits at the gas station the
other one drives around the block comes
back up here goes around the block again
drives past gets waved off again and
without stopping drives three and a half
miles all the way downtown here so now
you're asking yourself what the heck is
going on we believe that this is the
major drug delivery that all those armed
guards were prepared to receive and what
happened was is the other group killed a
guy in the middle of their drugs
but we got all that information from a
police report that said man found in an
alleyway shot no witnesses that's the
sort of power that the system can do
[Music]